american citizen
nice
benefits
yeah
pathetic
my erections are fine thank you this is
crystal meth how do you guys live on
under 134 000 a year jonah i'd prefer if
you didn't offer to shuttle our
employees to the abortion clinic oh
booge oh my god are you watching us
masturbate at work
tom told me to tell you that his pug elm
fell into a sinkhole in the park yes you
can get pregnant from that angle
abortion abortion abortion abortion
abortion she dug your own grave so when
we do need to masturbate where are we
supposed to go toilet paper eggs shaving
cream i will kill myself before i go
back to 2d ultrasound okay
i will kill myself okay what if someone
steals a baby
[Music]
gotcha you gorgeous piece of garbage
dina's right eye on people
and your head is going on my wall i
think you got to kill that baby hitler i
like to go extra make sure everything's
up to code glenda g nothing glenn gary
glenn lost glennoma
sue transglander
i'm you i used to think kangaroos were
real
i'm bad y'all pretend i'm not here i
didn't set out to have a baby
came from sex we get it sandra tom hanks
is a space man whose life is saved by a
bunch of nerds i wish i wear a mermaid
the last time we saw the thumb it was in
a tub of guacamole and how did they used
to you know
penis penis penis that
was something i shouldn't have said
i'm pregnant not today you're not
okay prom is there a prom around i hope
you die well i
put on the hoodie that covers my face
and i take the 47 bus line to a library
in a far away town
then i open a private browser on one of
their computers and google home thinking
of killing her to see what mistakes
people usually make
jesus merry christmas kids it's a
nightmare mrs doubtfire
silence of the lambs
that one where nicholas cage switches
faces and says he's gonna eat a peach
for hours ooh forrest gump that's a good
movie
[Music]
i have a lot of cool sneakers and
a very active sex life get that camera
out my face obviously we're never gonna
have zero tramplings but we can have
fewer tramplings
do you remember your first period would
definitely kill a wall sorry son the
hell ride it last forever anybody see
sully all right after a long day of work
it's nice to have a glass of wine and
reach into a stable boy's chest and pull
out his still-beating heart you know my
aunt was warm with two vaginas oh
yeah
hello chicago
i'm not stupid i have the arm strength
of a chimp
g-spot
gay
racist
mean
redhead
attention cloud 9 employees i am fine i
hope someone sets you all on fire and
you need a volunteer to put it out
sometimes when i'm playing the sims i
give myself a family in the event of a
tornado you want to go straight for the
eye of it that is where it is safest
want to be in puppy heaven
don't be a dick yeah i love waking up at
3 a.m to eat sandra's cold spinach
casserole
see you around a hole
could you please shut up i'm i'm brexit
like thrusting their pelvises
[Music]
marcus
is that your thumb
it was
1953 and medical science was all the
rage
you